inattendu spécial noël pour vous
remercier de votre fidélité
on a voulu vous faire un petit cadeau et
quoi de mieux que le musée des arts
forains qui accueillera dès le 26
décembre le festival du merveilleux pour
illuminer notre dernier rendez vous de
l'année ensemble nous allons donc ouvrir
quelques archives empaqueter avec amour
par les équipes de la
laddh messieurs bonsoir je voudrais
regarder la france au fond des yeux mine
c'est vrai beaucoup de jeunes apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène à un peu moins et si
vous ne réussissez pas ce qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le front fais les valises à paris
de ce qui lui arrive à la baule
[Musique]
chaque semaine l'inattendu observe
l'actualité contemporaine grâce aux
archives de l'ina et au travail des
journalistes de la rédaction camille
d'auxerre ludivine lopez géraldine
corner lavaud bonjour à toutes les trois
je crois que vous avez votre liste au
père noël ça tombe bien cette saison
alors qu'amy cette période de l'année
est une formidable source d'inspiration
pour les journalistes mais surtout pour
les grands enfants que nous sommes mais
oui vous avez raison en est à noël et
ouais voilà c'était un pari oui c'est
une source d'inspiration pour les grands
enfants que nous sommes mais noël c'est
avant tout la fête des enfants des vrais
des petits et puis surtout c'est
l'occasion pour les journalistes de leur
poser une question du style qui est le
père noël comment est-ce qu'ils passent
par la cheminée que ces questions
majeures des risques majeurs mais
surtout qui donne lieu à des réponses
majeur des petites pépites tous les ans
on le faisait déjà en
1963 mais au fait comment est-ce qu'il
distribue les jouer le père noël
et l'eau
enfin un camus âge ou alors eu une
petite boîte euros et à des ficelles
l'oiseau les joies qui la porte où il
les a trouvés
physique
afa maison des vaches d'un magasin il
est marié
avec qui
[Musique]
elle est jeune vous les vieilles femmes
en blanc
et qu'est-ce qu'elle fait pendant que
distribuer les jouets
alors géraldine je sais que vous êtes
gourmande ainsi si je sais que vous avez
déjà bien avancé votre calendrier de
l'avent oui bien sûr un calendrier de
l'avent c'est tout un tout un art quand
même c'est tous les jours une petite
cage tous les jours sans manger en tête
a pris la case aujourd'hui des jours et
qu'une double ben voilà un seul chocolat
par jour quel courage quelle volonté je
sais que vous en avez 2 nathanaël
approche approfondie ça triche est en
fait voilà moi je pense à trop dur
d'ouvrir qu'une seule classe par jour et
quand j'ai vu cette archive de 1969 où
ce petit garçon est tellement gourmand
qu'il fait une petite bêtise j'ai craqué
ce calendrier de l'avent un merveilleux
calendrier tout plein de dorures
et lorsqu'on ouvre à grand peine les
petites fenêtres qui s'y trouvent alors
on découvre des jouets des sapins
d'abéché où malgré l'interdiction qui
lui a été faite par mahmoud rêve
d'ouvrir toutes les fenêtres mais allez
donc comprendre les grandes personnes
maman et d une fenêtre chaque jour et
vite le coeur bat o d'être surpris
il ouvre dans une fébrile toutes les
petites fenêtres du beau calendrier s'il
est quelqu'un qui fut surpris par contre
ceux subis à ma main
qui tue pas le courage de gonder
alors le voir à la maman n'a pas le
courage de condé cet enfant mais comme
on le comprend nathanaël on a tous déjà
mangé des cases en avance sinon je ne
vois pas de quoi vous parlez vous
ludivine quel est le moment de noël qui
qui vous a marqué dans les archives bon
moi je vais un peu cassé l'ambiance
en regardant les archis moi j'ai un
moment que magma plus c'est en 1968
juliette gréco la chanteuse que vous
connaissez vous connaissez tous
parlaient de son désamour pour noël et
oui ça existe des gens qui n'aiment pas
noël
je passerai noël peut être seul on peut
être de temps avec michel sylla
c'est là le temps à la possibilité de
prendre un avion parce qu'il sera
à hollywood a
snobé n'est ce pas
non jamais petit jésus la lettre je
n'aime pas les fins d'années je n'aime
pas beaucoup les faits
je crois je crois que les gens les gens
qui n'ont pas eu quand il était enfant
la véritable joie de noël véritable joie
d'une famille et eni et et reuze je
crois que il ya toujours une espèce de
mélancolie terrible je préfère
lâchement rester chez moi est ce que
vous savez comment s'appelle toutes ces
personnes qui n'aime pas noël je pose
acquise on a tous fait un nom oui c'est
un nom bien sûr les rabat joies
et les noms presque non non non vous
n'avez pas du tout ok c'est ce sont les
natal au phoque donc ce sont
des personnes publiques de nathan a
annoncé ce sont les personnes publiques
de noël donc ce sont les nattes
allophones ils sont des personnes qui
ont en horreur tout ce qui touche de
près ou de loin à noël les illuminations
les repas le génial
messi sait rien c'est sérieux ces
troubles quand même cette phobie est un
trouble anxieux bon on va tenter de leur
faire passer leur natale aux phobies en
leur offrant un de ses nombreux petits
plaisirs de noël les chansons qui
célèbre la l'activité alors vous les
connaissez
toutes ces chansons j'en suis sûr et
c'est justement le thème du zapping de
l'inattendu et je vais faire un truc
c'était pas prévu mais j'en avais très
envie
aa
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ma plus belle lui
depuis la nuit des temps
c'est la nuit de noël
la lui d'un pauvre enfant
[Musique]
duhai
à
quaresma
oh
blanc
[Musique]
la cheminée
petit garçon
là le second chez oh
à
[Musique]
lui faudra
le
c'est moi
c'est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le ca
c'est un sujet de conversation qui
pimentent parfois souvent le
traditionnel réveillon la politique
s'invite pendant les fêtes de noël a
fortiori à quelques semaines quelques
mois d'une présidentielle
les enjeux sont d'ailleurs immense pour
les candidats un sapin moche ou un noël
raté peuvent avoir des conséquences lors
du scrutin à l'elysée l'arbre de noël
est d'ailleurs une tradition chaque
année le président de la république et
la première dame invite des enfants oui
absolument nathanel et c'est une
tradition qui a plus d'un siècle
la première fois c'était en 1889 sous la
présidence de sadi carnot ça fait un
certain temps et puis dont des enfants
des centaines d'enfants viennent
traditionnellement à quelques jours de
noël à l'elysée alors c'est une
tradition un petit peu mise entre
parenthèses ces derniers temps qu'ovide
oblige des enfants dont qui viennent et
qui sont des enfants des employés de
l'elysée ou bien des pupilles de la
nation des enfants aussi qui viennent
d'outre-mer des premiers de la classe
des quartiers défavorisés bref des
centaines d'enfants qui arrive à
l'elysée qui déride un petit peu cette
maison et qui déride aussi les
présidents
il n'y a qu'au noël de l'elysée qu'on
peut voir ça
[Musique]
valéry giscard d'estaing au piano et sur
une chaise un peu trop petit pour lui et
claude françois au micro pour un douce
nuit sainte nuit fredonner aux enfants
en 1975
le noël de l'elysée c'est une tradition
vieille de plus d'un siècle à laquelle
tous les présidents ce sont six à la
veille de noël le président et madame
orioles ont donné rendez vous au père
noël dans les salons de l'elysée grâce à
cette rencontre des centaines de petits
parisiens ont vécu le plus beau noël de
leur vie le plus beau noël de leur vie
rien que ça en tout cas à l'elysée rené
coty savait recevoir petit four pour
tout le monde en 1954 500 écoliers de
paris les plus sages bien entendu sont
venus goûter les petits fours et les
meringues que leur offrait le président
et madame coty en compagnie du père noël
les plus sages évidemment mais aussi les
enfants des employés de l'elysée des
écoliers de toute la france ou des
orphelins pupille de la nation des
enfants triés sur le volet bien non
dimanche et pour l'occasion pressé
d'entrer au palais et à chaque président
un style différent le général de gaulle
recevait en tenue militaire et face à
lui des enfants qui ne bougent pas d'un
cil je vous souhaite un heureux noël est
une très bonne année
ses voeux en même temps qu'à vous vont
avant famille à ce beau m qui vous ont
accompagné et tous ensemble nous portons
nos meilleurs choix vers la france
georges pompidou lui était plus
décontracté on m'a dit que vous étiez
sage est tout à fait sûr
il n'a aucun de diable
et bien c'est dommage
qu'ils soient des enfants sages ou des
petits diables il y a trois passages
obligés au noël de l'élysée le goûter
toujours apprécié le spectacle parfois
un peu surréaliste exemple en 1974
valéry giscard d'estaing assure le show
et donne la réplique à nounours j'ai eu
avec monnoir fait au noir j'attends le
rapport
sur le sujet
[Musique]
et puis et les cadeaux non on sait pas
si on va la voir mais si tu vas en avoir
chaque année des cadeaux sont distribués
des mains du président et de la première
dame
mademoiselle eve c'est et avait reconnu
car l'état sous l'oeil des caméras le
noël de l'elysée c'est aussi l'occasion
pour le président de parfaire son image
de père de la nation d'hommes généreux
et souriant mais allez ne brisons pas la
magie de noël le plus important pour
mademoiselle eve et les autres c'est de
repartir les bras chargés de cadeaux
voitures télécommandées on a eu
cette année qu'on pouvait avoir des
aigles et groupe hélicoptères et surtout
les enfants on n'oublie pas de dire le
nom tu donnes mais il ya un mois
[Musique]
merci à guy cannie comment vous faites
merci alors je crois qu'un tir on le
tient
[Musique]
un petit tour en carrousel pour que la
fête soit plus belle que serait noël
sans le père noël géraldine attention à
ce que vous allez dire c'est un sujet
sensible certains de nos plus jeunes
téléspectateurs
croient encore au père noël peut être
même les moins jeunes ils attendent en
tout cas tous impatiemment son passage
par la cheminée alors n'allez pas dire
que c'est une invention jamais de la vie
jamais de la vie éternelle je ne dirais
pas ça en revanche pendant que le père
noël prépare vos cadeaux et il y en a
beaucoup vous avez été vraiment très
gourmand c'est vrai je l'admets je
l'admets le père noël fait appel à des
doublures des doublures que l'on voit
dans les jt depuis très longtemps est
une chose est sûre ces quatre doublure
du père noël c'est un métier vraiment
pas facile
et qu'est ce que tu vas le commander
d'autres innover
pas simple de comprendre les enfants de
gaulle
voilà une photo ce sera plus simple être
souci du père noël c'est de l'endurance
surtout qu'ils ont parfois une seconde
vie bien loin de la magie de noël
m'avait dit que vous étiez également
catcheur oui
j'ai gâché nombreuses années avant
guerre et
je suis parce que des comédiens
cascadeurs qu'elle roule à vienne dans
le quand on est si les amateurs
c'est à l'opposé du personnage que vous
jouez actuellement oui ça repose que sur
l'axé pour d'autres le métier de sosies
de père noël est le plus pur hasard
c'est simplement une petite annonce
journal local je m'attendais pas du tout
adhéré à ce qu'on propose un travail de
père noël à vous dis tout de suite ce
n'est pas du tout ma vocation
j'étais deux ans principalement
instituteurs et j'étais guide aussi pour
une agence de voyages père noël c'est
bien payé ans s'est payé environ 11
milliards d'internautes elle tous les
hommes venant se première fois première
fois vous êtes devenu père noël comment
paris sinon comme ça si l'on peut dire
je n'ai pas de boulot j'ai un collègue
qui chaque chien de poche il m'a proposé
et c'est rentable vous gagnez combien
n'ont pas cette année pas du tout non
résumons pendant que le père noël
prépare tranquillement les jouets des
enfants ces sosies sont payés au smic
sont obligés de sourire et doivent
éviter de se faire tirer la barbe pire
encore ils risquent leurs vies et
légendes à brad pitt doit six membres
associés j'ai jamais d'avoir scène lol
je risque d'être présent en plus
d'attraper des microbes les père noël
souffre c'est très très chaud à porter
un masque si jobs c'est d'oublier
éprouvant toute la journée avec la
chaleur du centre hongrois tous ses
efforts pour au final faire plaisir aux
enfants
même pas ils ont peur ils pleurent
ambiance
je me régale j'adore les gosses
les pleurs sont les aléas du métier mais
pour ce père noël de 1996 il y avait
aussi des avantages les gens qui passent
ici me regarde ton des sourires des
clins d'oeil rigole
une fois que je me retrouve dans le
métro c'est vrai que c'est sordide tout
le monde tire la gueule personne ne
regarde personne ne me reconnaît
si personne ne le reconnaît c'est
peut-être que ce n'est pas lui le vrai
père noël difficile de sortir de son
rôle même les enfants s'y perdent
parfois
[Musique]
non alors des vrais des faux père noël
on envoie tout de même un petit peu
moins et oui un petit peu de moi cette
année il ya une vraie pénurie de père
noël et alors désolé rejette obligèrent
peuvent parler du coc vide mais c'est
bien à cause du coc vite qu'il ya moins
de père noël car les père noël bas sont
un peu vieux ou un joli embonpoint c'est
ça qui fait le déguisement et face au co
vie débat ils ont pas forcément envie
hein d'avoir toute la journée des
enfants qui leur font des bisous à la
chaîne des enfants qui leur tirent la
barbe ont lavé dans le sujet ils ont
peur d'avoir la varicelle ou la rose et
elle m'a alors voilà pour le coc vide
ils réfléchissent à deux fois avant de
mettre la houppelande et c'est carrément
chiffres et un aux états unis et au
canada il manque 800 mille huit cent
mille père noël dans les centres
commerciaux alors on va faut rassurer
les enfants tout de même en barrages ou
l'inde là je dois apprendre un peu
d'inquiétude on va rassurer tout le
monde le vrai père noël est évidemment
lui ne craint absolument rien et sera
bien présent pour mettre tous les
cadeaux au pied du sapin on est soulagé
on est soulagé
[Musique]
voilà ludivine on vous retrouve sur
cette attraction inspirée par la course
des garçons de café alors tout à l'heure
géraldine nous a parlé du père noël il
est temps maintenant de parler des
cadeaux bien sûr et bien justement les
cadeaux est ce que votre liste est prête
nathanaël elle est toute prête la voici
je voulais me la remettre à bas parfait
parfait vous avez de la chance parce que
moi j'avoue que cette année j'étais un
peu en mal en mal d'inspiration
heureusement je me suis inspiré des
archives de l'ina il faut dire
d'ailleurs je vous conseille un de faire
la même chose si vous avez allez voir
sur le site oui allez allez sur le site
et c'est vrai que dans les archives de
l'ina on trouve des idées assez original
parfois aussi bien loufoque voici ma
sélection
surprendre étonner ravir c'est la raison
d'être des gadgets chef-d'oeuvre
d'astuces et d'imagination
ce sont toujours des cadeaux appréciés
et aujourd'hui encore les gadgets sont
grandement apprécié c'est un cadeau
facile original dans les années 60 il
était incontournable et en même temps
comment résister à ce pull de places
inséparablement unis mais surtout pour
le pire
autre gadget un peu glauque je vous la
corde mais il m'a tapé dans l'oeil en
1966 la mode était à l'horreur
amateurs de poupées baigneurs et autres
bébés multifonctions cette sélection est
faite pour vous il y à tous les styles
dans les archives et poupées automates
qui font parfois un peu peur
des bébés qui pleurent forts
[Musique]
et ceux qui mangent mais pas que et
alors que le bébé aura terminé de manger
[Musique]
il est recommandé de lui donner à boire
afin qu'ils puissent évacuer normalement
les aliments absorbés après les poupées
les traditionnels peluche traverse aussi
les générations et se jouait tout droit
sorti des années 80 vaut le détour il
mesure 75 mètres de long à 15 mètres
près c'est la longueur d'un terrain de
football il s'agit d'une immense chauny
en peluche elle a trois mille pattes une
patte tous les 5 cm cette chenille
véritable mutation génétique des temps
modernes est arrivé des etats-unis par
avion à les inscrits au livre des
records après les jouets les vêtements
peuvent aussi compléter votre liste de
noël et pour vous afficher la dose de la
pochette de costumes il vous faut
celle-ci chine et dans les années 90
parce qu'une pochette une particularité
certaine c'est qu'elle tient sur un
support carton est toujours prête et sur
support n'est pas là la difficulté de la
mettre en position de problème de la
pochette pour finir et parce qu'on ne se
refuse rien voici une idée luxueuse
après tout c'est noël il faut que ça
brille
by birman cabochons de toute grande
qualité avec du jade des diamants
navettes des saphirs multicolores une
améthyste enfin tout ce qu'il y a comme
pierre précieuse objets grand luxe
gadget ou jouets traditionnels vous
n'avez plus qu'à faire votre choix père
noël à votre bon coeur
merci beaucoup ludivine pour votre
sélection elle m'a aussi donné des idées
pour tous les cadeaux que je dois encore
faire à mes proches il en reste
quelques-uns alors est-ce quelques-uns
oui c'est vrai que chaque année 1 c'est
un dilemme de trouver des cadeaux pour
les autres il faudrait s'inspirer cette
initiative qui date de
1966 l'équipe de cadeaux conseil
téléphonique était à l'écouté de toutes
les personnes en mal d'inspiration
un coup de fil et tout était réglé
[Musique]
cadeau conseil téléphonique je vous
écoute
bonjour monsieur
oui quel âge at elle
et combien voulez vous m
c'est une personne qui est coquette qui
aime bien les choses pour l'intérieur
elle n'a pas de goût particulier qui
pourrait m'aider par hasard
au elle adore le café mais si vous voyez
vous nous avons ici un petit percolateur
pour l'appartement qui vous donne du
café express tout comme mon café et en
plus
alors oui c'est un percolateur qui
marche à la vapeur comme au café un
percolateur qui voit la nuit du café
comme à l'italienne et en plus de ça
vous en profitez vous même c'est
merveilleux mois en percolateur c'est
merveilleux non alors non mais j'en ai
marre des percolateurs en tout cas
c'était l'idée cadeau de 1966 nathanaël
merci beaucoup ludivic j'ai hâte de
découvrir ce que le père noël m'a amené
au pied du sapin tiens un petit cadeau
pour vous on se quitte avec l'autre
pépite bien sûr une interview de jean
gabin fait par audiard est un sujet noël
bien sûr et mitraillettes et les poyas
recommande aux gens raffolent les
japonais aux coûts pour les adultes mais
pour les enfants je suis carrément
contre
non pour moi l'ol c'est la paix et je
trouve drôle de fêter la paix avec des
arcs bus paris cheminée c'est pour
circonstance noël c'est un sapin les
souliers dans la cheminée et des gosses
qui nous font le plus joli des cadeaux
celui d'être là
tu vois si j'avais pas été empêché par
la fatigue de faire cette émission et ce
genre de noël que j'aurais souhaité à
tout le monde
après tout je peux peut-être que je vais
qu'est ce que je risque
voilà c'est la fin de cette inattendue
réalisé dans le musée des arts forains
qui dès le 26 décembre vous accueillera
pour le festival du merveilleux non vous
attend le 6 janvier l'année prochaine
pour de nouveaux numéros de l'inattendu
d'ici là vous pouvez nous retrouver sur
les réseaux sociaux que ce soit ceux de
france info où se devine à merci à nos
documentaliste emilie galtier est clair
brûlé et merci à vous bien sûr d'être
présent chaque semaine bonnes fêtes à
tous
elle note annuelle
[Musique]